Prince Harry's upcoming Memoirs spare
causing further trouble amongst the
royal family they are verbal attacks on
members of the royal family and not just
any member of the royal family his
father his brother his mother-in-law his
sister-in-law no one is really spared in
spur in et's learned Prince William's
Furious a source tells E.T William fills
Harry crossed a line with the claims in
the book set to release January 10th how
has the book been received here over in
the UK well it is an explosive Memoir we
were promised an autobiography that was
raw and unflinching it has absolutely
delivered William is said to be
privately seething and and devastated by
his brother and what he has done in this
autobiography but he's also incredibly
angry at the level of detail which his
brother has shared in this book quote
the family is appalled that Harry has
revealed such private and learn great
details which are completely
inappropriate adding that he's gone
about dealing with it the wrong way the
problem is no family conversation can
ever take place because Harry claims he
and Megan are opposed to leaks and then
he and Megan share extremely private
family matters with the public they just
simply feel that any reconciliation is
not on the cards because they can't they
can't trust that it's not going to end
up in a TV show or in a book there's a
lot of anger and there's still a lot of
resentment and I think any reproachment
is is really quite far down the line
Willie will be taking this very
personally I think he's incredibly upset
and feels very badly betrayed by his
brother
on top of the revealing Memoir Harry's
taking part in multiple televised
interviews for 60 Minutes ITV and Good
Morning America previewing what's to be
expected you know the family motto is
never complained never explain but it's
just a motto I think there's probably a
lot of people who after reading the book
will go how could you ever forgive your
family for what they've done I would
like to get my father back I would like
to have my brother back at the moment I
don't recognize them as much as they
probably don't recognize me how would
your mom feel about your relationship
with your brother now
I think she would be
I think she would be sad Prince Harry
has given a number of interviews ahead
of the release of his autobiography and
he speaks about wanting to reconcile
with his family he talks about the door
being open but I think the feeling is
that actually he's made sure that door
has been firmly slammed shut UC is also
learning the book is deeply upsetting to
King Charles our source continues while
the relationship is extremely strained
he is a father first and understands
that family disagreements do transpire
if Harry genuinely wanted to work things
out of course people would listen well I
think everyone wants to see of repair in
the Riff because it doesn't do anyone
any good to have this rift at the heart
of the House of Windsor
that's true
[Music]